wealth is not to feed our egos
but to feed the hungry
and to help people help themselves
a library outranks any other thing a
community can do to benefit its people
it is a never failing spring in the
desert
a man who acquires the ability to take
full possession of his own mind
may take possession of anything else to
which he is justly entitled
there is no class so pitiably wretched
as that which possesses money and
nothing else
i resolve to stop accumulating
and begin the infinitely more serious
and difficult task of wise distribution
people who are unable to motivate
themselves must be content with
mediocrity
no matter how impressive their other
talents
no man becomes rich unless he enriches
others
it marks a big step in your development
when you come to realize that other
people can help you do a better job than
you could do alone
the man who dies rich
dies disgraced
put all your eggs in one basket and then
watch that basket
surplus wealth is the sacred trust
which its possessor is bound to
administer in his lifetime for the good
of the community
when fate hands us a lemon
let's try to make lemonade
if you want to be happy set a goal that
commands your thoughts
liberates your energy
and inspires your hopes
all human beings can alter their lives
by altering their attitudes
perhaps the most tragic thing about
mankind
is that we are all dreaming about some
magical garden over the horizon
instead of enjoying the roses that are
right outside today
do your duty and a little more
and the future will take care of itself
as i grow older i pay less attention to
what people say
i just watch what they do
there is little success where there is
little laughter
i don't believe in god
my god is patriotism
teach a man to be a good citizen and you
have solved the problem of life
and while the law of competition may be
sometimes hard for the individual
it is best for the race because it
ensures the survival of the fittest in
every department
all honors wounds are self-inflicted
ninety percent of all millionaires
become so through owning real estate
the best portion of a good man's life
his little
nameless
unremembered acts of kindness
and of love
the first man gets the oyster
the second man gets the shell
i believe that higher wages to men who
respect their employers
and are happy and content are a good
investment
yielding indeed big dividends
i am as a speck of dust in the sun
and not even so much in this solemn
mysterious unknowable universe
do not look for approval
except for the consciousness of doing
your best
a sunny disposition is worth more than
fortune
young people should know that it can be
cultivated
that the mind like the body
can be moved from the shade into
sunshine
if you want to get rich
think of saving as earning
no man will make a great leader who
wants to do it all himself
or to get all the credit for doing it
the fastest way to double your money
is to fold them in half
and put them in your pocket
every act you have ever performed since
the day you were born
was performed because you wanted
something
think of yourself as on the threshold of
unparalleled success
a whole clear glorious life lies before
you
achieve
concentration is my motto
first honesty
then industry
then concentration
you must capture and keep the heart of
the original and supremely able man
before his brain can do its best
the men who have succeeded are men who
have chosen one line and stuck to it
aim for the highest
you